quand vous êtes en manque pas d'accuser
mais qu'est-ce que ça et à bonjour
françois tiens tu as des nouveaux
panneaux et il te plaise boire ce sont
des ballons ouidah évidemment sont pas
des caramels mous dit dota dans ce ca
progresse très bien
regarde j'ai trouvé un nouveau pas à
bout à bout c'est bien bon justin
pendanx ce quoi c'est un pas de danse
mais c'est un très joli pas de danse ah
bon dit françois oui à propos des
ballons ils sont très beaux je te
remercie casimir tiens quelqu'un à
acheter des vieux papiers sur la pelouse
c'est idiot de salir notre jardin ouais
je trouve ça scandaleux
oui si on laisse les gens jeter des
papiers dans les halls et ça va devenir
un véritable dépotoir c'est vrai mais
j'ai une idée
ah bon grâce à ma merveilleuse mal
magique oui
plus personne ne jettera vieux papiers
avant tu va arranger secte est magique
voilà casimir tu vas voir ta balle
magique et voit la défense de jeter des
papiers sur la pelouse très bien casimir
et maintenant les gens vont les jeter
dans les allées c'est vrai et oui pas
tant
voilà défense de jeter des papiers dans
les allées ça c'est très bien casimir
midi dont c'est un petit peu dangereux
de laisser cette pancarte en plein
milieu de l'allée si quelqu'un fait pas
attention
il vise de la rt se faire mal c'est vrai
tu as raison je vais arranger ça comment
regarde voilà la décence de ne pas faire
attention à la pancarte écoute casimir
sais c'est pas très sérieux de ce tout
et pancartes comme ça n'importe comment
le remède est pire que le mal casimir
les gens vont vous pas pouvoir avancer
non non ça ne sera pas du tout kazimierz
est pas au point
je crois que tu as raison ah oui alors à
temps voilà interdit de poser des
pancartes quasi mai mais qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est pourquoi vous avez mis
des pancartes partout juste fou interdit
de poser des pancartes d'efforts de feu
de ne pas faire attention à la pancarte
mais c'est complètement farfelu votre
truc parfois lui casimir cherchait un
moyen pour empêcher les gens de gâcher
la beauté du jardin aux jetons des vieux
papiers partout mais le résultat n'est
pas très fan de nom voilà alors qu il
vaut peut-être mieux que j'enlève mes
parents car oui oui faudrait mieux
à quand même il est plus beau comme ça
notre âge arbre une pancarte
maintenant il s'agit de ramasser les
papiers
oh oui les papiers quel dommage que ce
qu'il ya encore casimir et bien ses
papiers
c'est moi qui les ai mis à sécher
comment casimir c'est toi qui achetait
ses vieux papiers sur la pelouse battue
a du toupet tous ces aléas les que les
ramasse en vitesse mais non et pourquoi
parce que je n'en ai plus besoin c'est
papier s'est fait à envelopper les
trains qui m'ont servi à écrire les
penta et j'ai plus près ah oui mon mec
ou de tout ça ça ça m'est complètement
égal casimir il ne faut pas laisser des
vieux papiers traîner sur les pousse à
aller à la ramasse tout ça allez hop
bon d'accord alors attention tous les
papiers d'ici allez hop les points il
reste europe
voilà ça alors que aimé
[Musique]